tras un mes de receso el parlamento
israelí inició esta tarde su periodo de
verano con el distintivo de que contó
con un discurso de Kevin mccarthy el
primer líder de la cámara de
representantes estadounidense que se
dirige a la kenneset en 25 años una
singularidad que responde uno a quema
carciso que Israel fuera su primer viaje
al extranjero Y dos a una reivindicación
de la amistad entre Israel y Estados
Unidos que trajo consigo una delegación
bipartidista tanto de republicanos como
de demócratas en contraste al trato frío
y crítico del presidente Joe biden
mccarthy se mostró cercano al Primer
Ministro israelí Benjamín netanyahu y
coincidió tanto con él como con el líder
opositor yace lápiz en que el objetivo
común es en sus palabras frenar a Irán y
su desarrollo de armas nucleares así
como sus agresiones contra Israel y su
influencia en toda la región además de
profundizar las relaciones con los
vecinos árabes durante esta apertura
todo fueron sonrisas y camaraderías Pero
la realidad es que este nuevo ciclo
parlamentario se enfrenta a dos grandes
desafíos la aprobación de los
presupuestos antes de que termine mayo
fundamental para evitar una disolución
de este gobierno Y de nuevo la
controversia por la reforma del sistema
judicial del gobierno de netanyahu en su
alocación en la que en este netanyahu
dijo estar comprometido a alcanzar el
consenso más amplio que se pueda aunque
el opositor y exministro de defensa
beniggans reveló más temprano que los
diálogos mediados por el presidente
israelí Isaac gersox no están
progresando en absoluto sobre ningún
tema